Venom's massive success at the box
office made a sequel virtually
guaranteed confirmed details are all but
non-existent at this point but rumors
and spoilers have already started
leaking so here's a look at what we can
reasonably expect from venom 2 if you
were waiting for Woody Harrelson to show
up in venom and he had to wait until the
mid credits for a brief scene presumably
returning to his career as an
investigative journalist Eddie Brock is
summoned to San Quentin where Harrelson
waits in a cage
everything about the scene feels like
the foundation for a sequel and in may
2018 Harrelson confirmed he'd be showing
up in venom 2 if you're a Marvel Comics
fan then the hints about Woody
Harrelson's role in Venom's mid-credits
scene weren't real subtle in the comics
Venom symbiote species reproduces
asexually and venom zone symbiote spawn
had the horrible idea of bonding to
serial killer Cletus Kasady
the result was the villain carnage he's
tougher than venom and has a body count
to rival the Joker's even though no one
in the mid credit scene says his name
with Harrelson's curly red wig the fact
that he's a convicted serial killer his
penchant for writing and blood and of
course his closing line now get out of
here and I will there's gonna be carnage
the signs point pretty hard to Venom's
bad guy having a bit more red coloring
in the second movie considering the
nature of the character it's surprising
venom didn't earn an R rating according
to the producer Avi arid venom 2 won't
be R either that's an even bigger
surprise with the likelihood of
Carnage's involvement in the sequel but
era doesn't think you need an R rating
to do carnage justice he told Collider
it's not about what he does because we
never have to show the knife going from
here to there
the venom producer described Cletus
Kasady as a soul filled with torment and
that he wants audiences to be able to
feel for him sympathetic villains can
certainly sell the success Tom
Hiddleston found as the MCU Loki is
proof of that and venom supports what
arrad says about not having to show all
the violence on screen for example we
know venom eats villains in the film
though we never actually see him do it
we'll see if the filmmakers can do
likewise with carnage but if the comics
are any indication they're gonna need to
kill a lot of people off screen a lot to
comic book purists divorcing Venom's
movie origin from spider-man may have
been more painful than a symbiote being
ripped from its host
but venom producer Ruben Fleischer seems
fairly sure the current live-action
versions of both characters will collide
on screen eventually speaking a Screen
Rant Fleischer said I'd love to see
venom face off against spider-man at
some point it feels like that's
inevitable Fletcher went on to say that
he knew both Tom Hardy and Tom Holland
were excited about the prospect and that
he didn't know whether or not that would
mean venom would or could become part of
the MCU so is it possible we could see
this inevitable clash in venom - it's an
enticing possibility especially if
carnage proves to be the sequel's
villain in the comics spider-man venom
and carnage have always worked as an
interesting trio of combatants
particularly with venom sometimes
flip-flopping between allies it's enough
to make you want to imagine that the
sequel to venom might be titled venom
maximum carnage considering Venom's
record-breaking success you'd think the
director could name his own price to
helm the sequel but variety pointed out
that it looks like venom director Ruben
Fleischer won't be able to direct venom
- whether he wants to or not
Fletcher directed 2009 s
post-apocalyptic comedies zombie land
and in July 2018 Sony confirmed the
production of zombie land - with pretty
much all of the original stars returning
as well as Fleischer who's set to direct
the sequel if lecture is going to be
busy directing zombie land - then it
could be difficult if not impossible for
him to also direct venom to the variety
article didn't offer any hints about who
if anyone Sony might be considering to
replace Fleischer it could be that since
both franchises are under Sony's tint
the studio is trying to find a way to
facilitate Fleischer helming both
projects before fishing for a successor
considering Harrelson will probably be
playing carnage and venom - as well as
appearing in Zombieland - maybe he and
Fleischer could just carpool or
something check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more lube
reviews about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]